[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos
iniciamos en argentina donde las
colillas de cigarrillo son uno de los
mayores contaminantes de las playas
porque el alquitrán y la nicotina se
adhieren al filtro tras la combustión
para poder descontaminar los
investigadores del laboratorio de
micología experimental de la universidad
de buenos aires descubrieron un tipo de
hongo especial capaz de realizar un
proceso llamado biorremediación este
tema no las trajeron desde una ong que
se dedicaba a juntar cigarrillos de la
playa y ellos estaban preocupados porque
vieron que si bien ellos los pueden
juntar no saben qué hacer después con
todo ese material que es tóxico nosotros
que trabajamos con hongos que son muy
buenos en biorremediación de distintas
contaminaciones mixtas decidimos probar
con algunas cepas que fuimos a buscar a
misiones si son cepas obtenidas en la
selva nosotros las aislamos y las
trajimos al laboratorio para tratar con
ello y nosotros generamos un
como si fuera un proceso digamos para
desintoxicar el material y después lo
que queda que sería el filtro de acetato
eso hay muchos lugares que ya pueden
reutilizarlos quienes reutilizan los
filtros de los cigarrillos tienen el
problema de los residuos tóxicos lo que
debe ser eliminado para poder volver a
usar el material las especies de hongos
que se usan crecen adheridas a los
troncos de los árboles y se comen el
acetato de celulosa del filtro se trata
de un proyecto que lleva 7 años de
estudio y se ha realizado con hongos de
pudrición blanca según los responsables
los filtros detoxificador se pueden
utilizar para fabricar pulpa de celulosa
materiales aislantes o incluso
incorporarse en materiales de la
construcción
ahora salimos de la tierra y vamos al
espacio porque el supertelescopio james
webb reveló dos impactantes imágenes de
júpiter el mayor planeta del sistema
solar las fotografías fueron tomadas con
la cámara de infrarrojo cercano que
cuenta con tres filtros especializados
para captar esta radiación invisible al
ojo humano y según los responsables del
proyecto dan pistas adicionales sobre
las condiciones internas de este cuerpo
celeste la combinación de varias
imágenes permite ver las auroras que se
extienden en los polos norte y sur a
gran altitud también son visibles nubes
más bajas brumas y neblinas superiores
un punto clave de las imágenes es la
llamada gran mancha roja que aquí se ve
en color blanco se trata de una tormenta
que según los expertos ha durado varios
siglos y lleva vientos de hasta 400
kilómetros por hora es el punto de mayor
calor en la atmósfera de júpiter de
acuerdo con los responsables las
numerosas manchas y rayas blancas
brillantes son probablemente nubes de
gran altitud de tormentas convectivas
condensadas
en una vista de campo amplio pues ve a
júpiter con sus anillos tenues que son
un millón de veces más te no es que el
planeta y dos lunas diminutas llamadas
amaltea y atrás tea
cambiamos de tema y vamos a hablar de un
barco robótico que se controla de forma
remota desde el reino unido- y que
comenzó a estudiar el volcán submarino
de tonga que entró en erupción en enero
pasado el buque max liner estaba
mapeando el borde del volcán para un
proyecto dirigido por el instituto
nacional de investigación del agua y la
atmósfera de nueva zelanda se trata de
un barco de 12 metros que ya completó
dos misiones de reconocimiento
nuestras dos primeras misiones han sido
la caldera del volcán que entró en
erupción en enero y hemos recopilado una
gran cantidad de datos para ayudar a los
científicos a comprender más al respecto
nuestra tercera misión que vamos a
realizar ahora es comprender un poco más
sobre el exterior del volcán las islas
aún no tienen internet con su cable de
datos así que vamos a mapear el terreno
para las islas de tonga y para que
puedan volver a explicar un cable
sin tripulación el barco puede tener una
fracción del tamaño de una embarcación
de inspección normal que transportaría
al tener una envergadura menor usa menos
combustible la erupción del volcán el 15
de enero generó olas de tsunami a través
del océano pacifico al tiempo los
satélites espaciales capturaron imágenes
de enormes nubes de ceniza y también de
una onda de choque atmosférica que se
irradió a una velocidad cercana a la del
sonido los datos recopilados por max le
maire ayudarán a los científicos a
comprender por qué la erupción tuvo un
impacto tan grande y violento así como a
predecir la naturaleza de futuras
erupciones es uno de los desafíos que
enfrentamos esencialmente cuanto más
veamos un territorio es que no sabíamos
cómo serían las profundidades así que
tuvimos que colocar algunos sensores
adicionales en la embarcación como un
sónar de visión frontal para que
pudiéramos ver los peligros antes de
tenerlos en frente pero obviamente
estamos controlando esta nave es de 16
mil kilómetros de distancia y lo estamos
haciendo por medio de datos otro de los
desafíos son nuestros ancho de banda y
la cantidad que podemos transmitir a
través de los satélites y también la
latencia de los datos en sí que
recibimos nos permiten navegar el barco
de manera segura pero también verificar
la calidad de los datos que recopilamos
durante múltiple sistemas y diferentes
sensores a gordos finalizamos en londres
con jurassic world the exhibition
justamente una muestra para los amantes
de la popular franquicia se trata de una
experiencia inmersiva con actores y
dinosaurios animatrónicos de tamaño
natural hay 6000 metros cuadrados de
exhibición y según los responsables está
diseñado para todos los gustos desde los
amantes de los dinosaurios gigantes e
imponentes hasta quienes prefieren
tiernos bebés así llegamos al final de
este espacio continúen con nosotros en
france24 france24 puntocom
[Música]